amateur footage captured the devastation  at the site of the crash buildings  destroyed wreckage scattered across this  residential neighborhood emergency  services rushed to the scene but it's  not thought any of those on board the  plane survived it's not yet clear  whether there were any fatalities on the  ground the most prominent casualty was  Brazil Socialist Party candidate Eduardo  Campos poles put the 49 year old in  third place for brazil's presidential  election his death throes campaigning  for the October vote into disarray it's  not known who will run in his place  campaign activities have been suspended  for three days as a mark of respect it's  not clear what caused the plane to come  down but aviation authorities say it had  been trying to land when it hit bad  weather